he might run into h5h4
he might have blown it yeah and just one
i mean he needs to move
yeah and that's it now it's a draw
unbelievable yeah
it's unbelievable
takes takes king and look at this poor
with it poor with it i mean he he
deserved what the performance it was
but but finally magnus halls
and that means that it
crashes out
but that also means that maybe prague
despite losing might still be dying for
for for eighth place and who knows what
the tiebreak will bring i'm afraid not i
can see the tiebreaks here i'm afraid
it's not good
prague i think he's out rapport is out
it looks like
but then who is in
it looks like anton and navarro are in
ah so the two davids so it means that
david navarre by winning this last game
we talked about this that he has done
everything what he could and
but he still needs to win it he still
needs to win it no david never won it
already ah you mean that david anton
yeah but okay i mean this is a this is
an element of in already
because if prague if